for your physical health so at what  point was the mental health lack  disregarded as a it's still there so  most of the abortions that actually  happened today by the letter of the law  in this nation are illegal or probably  illegal because most people think that  we have abortion on demand but we we  don't yeah they're meant so there's all  sorts of things where the abortion  Clinic's pre-scion forms and stuff like  that but that thing that Laura said is  very true that two doctors are meant to  sign off and give you a you know a woman  a kind of a consultation to see whether  they think that that there is some going  to be some mental issues